hello my name is Matthew Hussey author
of get the guy and this is a special
edition of what should I drew
Valentine's Day Edition I'm about to
answer some of your most burning
questions on love relationships and
Valentine's Day this one is from Sarah
who asks I am dating someone but we're
not exclusive so I've been going on
dates with other people and have been
honest about it but now they're getting
upset with me and feeling as if I'm
cheating on them am I in the wrong look
you're not in the wrong but I'm of the
opinion that if you really like someone
it's almost worth giving that a moment
and filling your life with other things
so that you're not relying on a text
from that person to make you feel good
so go out with your friends fulfill your
passions your hobbies you'll lose
yourself in your purpose your work so
that you still pace yourself give that a
minute to actually see if it feels like
it's promising because if you if you
already have that sense it doesn't mean
you're right it might not be promising
the most you'll lose is a couple of
weeks in seeing how that person is
showing up in your life and how they're
investing and if you don't like the way
they're showing up you can always point
out to them that hey I like you I was
kind of excited you know where this was
going but I didn't hear from you so I'm
not sure whether to put my energy
elsewhere that might be a safer route
than dating lots of people at the same
time when you already know that you and
another person have something
interesting to explore next question
Jesse asks my partner shuts down every
time I try to talk to them about what we
need to work on so I end up having to
reassure them instead of us working
together to make a change how do I make
sure we both get hurt what I hear from
that is your partner when you bring up
something you want to work on with them
they take it as damaging to their ego
that I'm doing something wrong but
you're not happy with me the key to that
is to show that you're coming just from
the point of view of I love you so much
I care about you so much I always one of
both of us to be able to bring to each
each other the things that we think can
take our relationship to the next level
or improve us so just tell them in a
random moment hey if there's anything I
can do to make you happy that I'm not
doing I always want to know about it
then you set the tone and it's like
you're putting credits in the bank
you're saying I can take feedback I can
take constructive criticism I can listen
to your needs and then when you do the
same you can always say if they get
defensive say I love you so much I just
always want us to keep working on our
relationship together and for our final
question Mason asks how do you know when
someone is interested in you I'm in my
early 30s and still no expert and kind
of embarrassed to admit this but
absolutely oblivious at times when to
others it's been obvious your gauge of
whether someone likes you can all it
doesn't have to be all or nothing like
I'm going to assume they like me and
then I'm going to walk up to them and
ask them out it doesn't have to be quite
that direct you can give a little bit
and see what happens like tease them a
little bit see if they tease you back
talk about a coffee place that you like
and want to go to and that you have half
an hour you might go there now and see
if they want to come with you you don't
have to immediately act as if I have to
have all the information right now to
know if they like me progress in inches
think about them almost like mini
experiments what happens if I initiate a
little physical contact with this person
what happens if I tease them what
happens if I say do you want to grab a
coffee if you find that they're
reciprocating on the same level then
just keep going it never needs to be
this All or Nothing of are they into me
are they not if they are I'm going to go
all in and if they're not I'm going to
back away run mini experiments so much
fun doing this with you guys have an
amazing Valentine's Day whether you're
single or in a relationship I'm Matthew
Hussey and I hope you enjoyed this
episode of what should I drew